two things are gonna happen first that  phone over there there's gonna ring  second you're gonna be wearing these  cuffs just gonna keep on ringing who the  hell are you I'm the guy you didn't  count on Jack Reacher Purple Heart  Silver Star you're a legend  what else have you heard I need your  help  woman's killing centers men that used to  be under your command it's time to start  hunting I don't know you're wrong this  year I promise you won't find out  nothing to find  maybe I rip your arm off beat you to  death  reaches to close how's it going  I want being followed you know you're a  dead man one of us is that's a certainty  is that fear right hearing your voice  Jack what you hear is excitement  sorry he's not feeling my morning is  this  you